we were thinking of some sets and we're
trying to work out because we knew that
for instance if you think about integers
uh i i think you guys would be on
natural numbers but i can make the same
argument for integers you'll see why
shortly
um there's an infinite number of numbers
in this set right which makes it a bit
difficult so when we compare these
we try and compare their signs right
there's a fancy little trick that i'm
going to show you which um it has to do
with something very pedestrian very
simple uh two proofs that are very very
different
and they both have to do
with diagonals you're like diagonals
what do diagonals have to do with
anything diagonals are really boring
like this is a diagonal right
here we go let's draw one in
that's a diagonal
what's useful about diagonals the answer
is a lot okay now before i show you how
they're useful let's make a heading
which is comparing the sizes of sets
okay so here's my question let's start
with an easy example
if we have two sets how do we compare
their sizes well depending on what the
sets are this is sometimes very easy
example
okay let's define a set let's use our
set notation okay
let's start with the set like say oh i
didn't know
um the prime number is under 10. prime
numbers under 10.
what are the prime numbers on the ten
uh
two
three
five
seven
that's it good
okay there's my wonky looking set all
right they go so the size of this set
the size of a
is four no big deal okay now i can name
any other set you like for instance if
we call b
oh i don't know let's call it
the even numbers
um
between not inclusive but between 10 and
20. even numbers between 10 and 20. can
we do that
i think it'd be 12
14
16
sorry 10 to 20. i'm gonna say 10 20. i
was thinking 20 and i said 12. sorry so
there you go there's even numbers
between 10
and 20. is that okay
so
therefore the size of b
is also four okay so you're like what's
the big deal i know the size this one i
know the size of this one therefore
they're the same
okay so in comparing the sizes of these
sets the way i do it is will i work out
what the size of each one is i see that
they're identical so i say the sizes are
identical okay now i hope you can see
and some of you came up against this as
you started to argue with yourselves on
your personality
you can't apply this logic to these sets
you can't do it right because if for
instance instead of a i said well let's
make a you know this okay
you're going to be counting forever
you might say you might say well the
size of this set is
you know infinite okay but infinity is
not a number it's not like oh there it
is and i've got it you know written on a
card okay it's an idea it's a concept
it's a useful one
i can count and never get to the end but
it doesn't help us answer this question
okay
so how do we do it let me give you
another illustration of this same
picture okay but a different kind of
process right
let's draw these sets but let's do it in
a bit of a um let's do it in a venn
diagram okay so
i've got a and b over here you'll notice
i've drawn it like these right because
have a look at the numbers in the sets
we have a name for these two sets and
how they relate to each other there are
no elements in common so they are
they are disjoint or they're mutually
exclusive either a phone okay
so i'm going to put all the elements in
there sorry stick with blue at this
point two three 5 7
12 14 16 18. okay now because they have
the same size i can do this
i can say look
every element in each of these sets
right can be matched or paired
with an element in the other set look we
can draw it that's true let's put the 2
in the 12.
yes this is function let's start with
the 3 with the 14
let's put the 5 with it just to shake it
off okay let's put the 5 with the 18. oh
wow i know just stand back everyone uh
seven with the
16. okay look see privilege i have
matched up
every element from set a with every
element in set b okay now you're like
what's the big deal we already
established this but the reason why this
is useful why this is a better approach
is because
i want you to now picture okay um you go
to you go to job purchase you walk
across the street okay and then you see
a whole bunch of boys and girls and you
know what do they do they're like doing
some dance aerobics or something like
that you're like
i wonder i wonder
if i want to compare the size of the
sets of boys
and girls okay so i'm trying to compare
these and thankfully they are mutually
exclusive okay now
you can do this one way which is i can
count them all up but you're like ah you
know little kids they're all moving
around i'll keep losing track that kind
of thing it's a difficult thing to do
okay
so instead of counting one and then
counting the other and trying to come up
with the same number here's what i'll do
i'll do this instead
i'll just say look every boy right go
find a girl
however many of you there are okay so
you know you've got boy one boy two boy
three and so on right and then you've
got girl one and girl two and girl three
and so on and you don't know how many
they are but if at the end after they've
all sorted themselves out and hopefully
gotten over girl germs right if they
have all
matched up
you don't need to know how many there
are
because you have matched up every single
one with another one in the other set so
then you can say okay the set of boys
and the set of girls same size does that
make sense
if i can match them up like this
then i can say the sizes are equal even
if i don't know what the sizes are